es ist Fußball EM der Herren in
Deutschland nächstes Jahr und keine Sau
interessiert warum ich glaube weil
Fußball nicht mehr spektakulär genug ist
deswegen hier einige Vorschläge damit
Fußball wieder geil wird Vorschlag
Nummer 1 in der Nachspielzeit müssen
beide Mannschaften jeweils drei Spieler
einwechseln die über 70 Jahre alt sind
die Chance für Beckenbauer noch mal zu
zeigen was in ihm steckt Vorschlag 2
Fußball nur noch mit den Händen spielen
und Tor gegen Korb austauschen könnt mir
vorstellen dass Deutschland gut darin
ist Vorschlag Nummer 3 einfach aber
genial zweiter Ball das Spiel mit einem
Ball macht Spaß mit zwei bäen doppelt so
viel Fun vier viel kürzeres Spiel eine
Halbzeit dauert nur noch 15 Sekunden
Social Media tauglich tiktok und so
Vorschlag 5 Löwen zu einem bestimmten
Zeitpunkt des Spiels kommen Löwen aufs
Spielfeld Vorschlag 6 jeder Spieler der
ein Pass versemmelt muss ein Geheimnis
mit allen Teilen das noch niemand weiß
bin gespannt wie viel coming Outs wir
erleben werden Vorschlag 7 the Perge es
gibt eine Minute ohne Regel und zu guter
Letzt Bayern München darf nicht
mitspielen ach die dürfen sowieso nicht
mitspielen mega geil